[موسيقى]
اذا كنت لا ترغب في فعل شيء تحمل جهاز
التحكم التلفاز
وتقلبوه بلا وجهه محدده او تقلبوا في
هاتفك المحمول بلا فائده فانت حتما مصاب
بالملل ولا تعرف كيفيه التخلص منه
[موسيقى]
الملل كغيره من الاحاسيس حاله عاطفيه قد
يمر بها الانسان عندما لا يشعر بالاهتمام
بما يحيط به من اشخاص او اثاره فيما
يمتلكه من اشياء عندها يفتقده لشغف
ويصبحوا ابعد ما يمكن على التركيز فيما
يفعل كان ياكل بلا سبب او يمشي دون احساس
بالوقت ويدخن دون النظر لعلبه السجائر
التي احرقتها لحظات من التجار القاتل
[موسيقى]
وين الملل انواع اصعبها ذلك الذي يقود
للاكتئاب السريري الذي قد يؤدي للخلل
الادراكي والفشل باكتساب المعرفه ولكن
الشيء الجيد بالملل بالنسبه للاشخاص
المتحفزين في طبيعتهم انه يدفعهم دوما
للبحث عن الجديد الممتع والمفيد الذي يكسر
وحده ملالهم ويزيد من انتاجيتهم
[موسيقى]
وفي النهايه لابد من تذكر مقوله ان علاج
افه الملل لابد ان يكون بالمزيد من العمل
صباح العربيه ندى حجازي القاهره